[Music]
all right hello plastic pills listeners
today matt and i are talking to jack
black a senior lecturer at sheffield
hallam university jack black's research
focuses on media and cultural studies
drawing on philosophy and psychoanalysis
his published works have covered diverse
topics like english nationalism sports
ecology and covid19 today we are talking
to jack purely because i discovered a
tweet that referred to his recently
published book race racism political
correctness and calm in comedy a
psychoanalytic exploration combining two
of our favorite topics at the pill pod
comedy and psychoanalysis and bringing
it to bear on a spicy topic like comedy
and racism i couldn't really resist so
i'm excited to have you here jack black
welcome to the show hello yes thank you
for that and thanks for having us
yeah we're really excited to have you so
uh before we get into the kind of nuts
and bolts of your book in particular
like the kind of theoretical
underpinnings i was just wondering what
provoked you to take an interest in this
topic in particular and
everyone has a kind of vision of what
political correctness means but could
you maybe define political correctness
and why you think it's worthy of this
kind of theoretical interpretation yeah
um well
first off and i always find this odd
because there's a couple of times where
i've spoken about the book and i do
rather than speaking about my book i go
straight to talking about elenka
shapanji it's great uh book on comedy
the odd one in and it was it was purely
from reading that um
that book in particular that i then
started to get sort of these ideas
around uh around comedy and how comedy
could be used in a subversive way to
perhaps uh in a sort of you know to
challenge dominant ideologies um
or for example to challenge something
such as political correctness and i
think
one of the things i think that was
interesting about political correctness
i've done research before on sort of
race and racism and multiculturalism
um and there seemed to be there seemed
to be a particular period i'm thinking
about sort of i must i think it was
around 2017 where you had
certain comedians like louis ck um
you know who was who who
for rightly or wrongly i would have
probably called a subversive comedian
before obviously you know his sexual
harassment um sort of scandal came out
and then there was other instances i
start the book talking about an instant
about uh
uh constantine kissing who's uh within
the uk who was
meant to do a comic gig
the uh in university of london's uh
school of soas
uh but ended up having to sign some sort
of behavioral agreement that said don't
you know you can't say anything that's
you know transphobic homophobic racist
or anything like that and he sort of
made quite a fuss about that appearing
on television in the press that he
refused to do the gig because he had to
sign this sort of behavioral agreement
um so there seemed to be this sort of
link between me sort of reading the book
and then me sort of having these comic
examples that were sort of going around
at the time and i suppose one of the
things which drew me into political
correctness was there was never really a
definition
specifically
of what political correctness was there
seemed to be this history that it
emerged um it emerged predominantly from
the left i remember as an undergrad
reading stuart hall had written sort of
early essays and then chapters as well
on political correctness
and it was often seen as a sort of it
had this sort of ironic flavor to it
that if you weren't following the party
line um
you know you were being or if you
followed the party line too much you
were being politically correct so it
always had this link in my opinion to
subversion and the fact that it wasn't
very well defined the fact that for me
what made political correctness quite
interesting was that it could be used
for both
the opposing ends i think really it
could be used as something that the
right wanted to use but also something
that the left wanted to use which is why
i started to focus on it and i started
to think more more critically about how
it had this sort of ideological function
i suppose and naturally you know i've
sort of drawn and had been using zgex
works which draw that sort of
ideological link there
absolutely so i mean g-check obviously
writes voluminously on the topic of
political correctness uh and why the
left should steer clear of it but before
we get into that i was wondering could
you talk a little bit about why the
political right in particular has
transformed this into such a subject of
almost manic discourse uh and you refer
to a couple of the figures uh over the
course of yearbook people like jordan
peterson right who kind of came to the
forefront
of political culture right there wrongly
by attacking pc uh by talking about you
know how social justice was a big danger
why is it that the political right is so
fixated on these things
yeah i think i think it's because they
take the
it takes the ball completely out of the
left's hands i think what they're very
good the political right is if you make
it about culture if you make it about
identity then you'll you're always
locked in this this this battle between
the particulars between
uh you know between the various
multitude of ways that your identity can
be split up into you know being a a
white heterosexual man versus a disabled
black woman you know what i mean you
know and i think that what the rights
really good at is when it when it makes
that the
the terrain of the debate uh then then
the left's never gonna win because i
think you get into this sort of fight
where you're having to protect and make
the argument for
your political identity uh you're having
to fight your corner so to speak rather
than looking towards perhaps more
universal uh arguments that could be
made or sort of or plans plans there so
i think it it favors you know it favors
um
it favors the right i mean jordan
pearson's such an odd example in all
those contexts because
it seems i don't i don't know what
happened there you know because john
peterson wasn't an academic on political
correctness or any sort of cultural
issues i mean this was i mean i mean i
don't know i don't know his academic
background that well i think i spoke to
one person actually who studied at
university teaches that and attended one
of his lectures it was essentially all
about myth wasn't it if i'm quite right
he's original you know the power of myth
and the way in which myths and fantastic
fantasies work within
uh within culture and it seems to be
that one youtube video where he's
arguing with the student about the is it
a toilet or the cisgender and off the
back of that he then became this
figurehead
for this sort of you know call it
alt-right or
um
yeah what was as you know this sort of
dissonant against any form of council
culture or political correctness
um and i suppose yeah he's capitalized
on that quite well i suppose yeah well
matt you wrote matt actually wrote a
book for zero books on on it and i don't
know if uh yeah like you spent you
actually did spend a lot of time reading
his academic work hey matt
yeah more time than anyone should spend
um so i don't want to make this about
peterson but
this kind of has this argument you can
call it like a jungian argument uh i
think that's also doing a bit of a
discredit to young but basically the
idea is that you know
society is defined by this balance
between order and chaos right archetypal
order and archetypal chaos and the best
kind of society is one that achieves a
kind of harmony between the two and he
feels that we've been shifting too far
towards chaos which he associates for
very ambiguous reasons with the
political left right the striving for
equality emancipation from tradition uh
and
political correctness is symptomatic uh
of that along with a variety of other
cultural ills right so that's putting it
in the cole's notes right um it's
actually a shame i think because one of
the things that i was interested in
seeing with his debate with the
slavajishek was going to be this kind of
right psychoanalytic versus left
psychoanalytic take i was really hoping
for that right since a lot of people i
know are still very attracted to young
but that never really emerged and said
they just kind of
talked past each other uh about bad
readings of the communist manifesto and
nothing really substantial came from it
yeah
yeah i mean
well i just i mean that to me i mean
that was just there was no preparation
there from jordan peterson um i think on
his behalf i think
i i would definitely sort of
actually i would have you know after
using his work but i think what gjp did
there was he tried to set the terms of
the debate which i think is the only
thing you could do it's hard to argue
jordan peterson because he's such a
brilliant
uh
you know you know you know he's very
good presenting isn't it i think it's
like an order yeah it's like i mean i've
had yeah definitely i mean i've had
first year students who are like
we sort of come up and we'll give you
this idea of this video that they've
watched jordan peterson online you're
like oh christ alright and you have to
like chip away at that a bit but um but
it's because he presents it in such a
way that sort of matter of fact common
sense sort of way where you think well
perhaps there's something in it and i
think
yeah i think what jesus was very good he
made it i mean i think he called him out
on a couple of occasions didn't he
because you know jordan peterson was
just reciting the most rehashed
general
criticisms wasn't he of marxism and the
communist manifesto and i think there
were points where he said well where
where who are these people then who are
yeah yeah that was definitely a good
moment
yeah i think i think yeah and i think
that was i think that was the key bit of
that debate yeah i mean that was
yeah the whole thing was although that
debate i always find didn't you i mean
it was such a weird moment i couldn't
especially in the uk we get nothing like
that in the uk like too academic
i mean there's there's the constantly
rehashed video isn't there a trumpsky
and foucault debating
in french
and i just realized thinking about what
reality was this this world where
it's good debate on television but um i
mean i know yeah well it was super
popular in toronto i mean people pointed
out that it was more expensive and more
difficult to get tickets to that debate
than it was to get maple leaf tickets uh
which is quite something if you know the
toronto maple leafs because even though
they're a shitty team uh they are
popular
yeah it was expected by the end uh yeah
i actually was there but i got tickets
pretty early with my friend and they
were like i don't know i think they were
like 35
so still like kind of expensive to watch
academics debate but by the end i
remember one of my professor friends i
was like oh you should come he tried to
get tickets and by that point they were
up to like three hundred dollars four
hundred dollars it was crazy that's mad
i mean what was it like there in the
debate i don't know i mean it was uh
i mean i was up in the nosebleed section
it's like kind of a big a big like
theater and i remember no like feeling
it was interesting being in line like
speculating about like okay who's like
who's the peterson bro who who are the
zuzia bros here like and i was trying to
figure it out and like sometimes it was
hard to tell and like you could it was
interesting to be around in certain
moments some people would cheer and then
you could tell like they were more for
for peterson
and then i think and i was like at one
point i think someone yelled
during peterson's uh like little i think
undergrad level presentation on the
communist manifesto like it's a [ __ ]
pamphlet bro like why are you taking it
so seriously
and i think you got kicked out actually
i think you got you got like escorted
out of uh by security um
but yeah it was interesting well this
actually is a kind of a good segue to
the next question that i wanted to ask
you and then i know victor uh has
something that is really pressing um but
one of the things that i think peterson
and people like charlie kirk for example
i've really been able to capitalize on
is the sense of being contrarian or
counter culture which is ironic when you
think that they're pretty stodgy
conservative people right you know
traditional values traditional gender
roles and stuff and the reason they're
able to present this way
is in part because they're able to claim
that the problem with pc is that it's
neutered safe
kind of authoritarian
not directly authoritarian in the sense
that the state is kind of operating to
suppress speech but social pressure is
kind of being applied to suppress speech
and that's really kind of ironic i think
because of course we would usually
associate this kind of contrary and
counter cultural attitude with the
political left uh and yet political
correctness is so associated with
progressive activism so i was wondering
if you could speak a little bit about
this really strange tension and why it
is that you think the political right
has been able to present itself uh as a
kind of counter-cultural movement in
response to these kind of developments
yeah that's good that's a really
interesting question i think
i think i think it's the fact that i've
always come back to it's very similar to
what you know i was i was suggesting
before i think i think you'll always win
the the particular argument so if you
need to start vouching for a particular
side
then then you're gonna win that because
people enjoy their identity so to speak
don't they they enjoy you know where
they're from or what they're what they
represent and i think one of the things
that you know someone like peterson's
very good i mean it's to me to to boil
it down it's self-help essentially
that's that's essentially what i think
jordan peterson is so i think he gives
you know during a period of the decline
of symbolic efficiency you know you know
the symbolic order the big other you
know god doesn't exist i think someone
like jordan peterson uh you know if
you're associating with him the with him
as being on the right so to speak i mean
it'd be interesting i don't know if he
would even
admit to being on i don't i think that's
that much he's recently uh
basically become overt about the fact
that he embraces a kind of conservatism
in his latest book the beyond order one
um he said you know to the extent i'm a
conservative it's because i support you
know slow incremental change kind of a
mild reverence for tradition kind of
ordered liberty uh if you think about
like the anglo-american tradition okay
so i mean so that's interesting so i
think i think the fact what he makes
what he sort of is able to support there
is this this this this focus on the
particular this focus on the order
taking that as you said there that uh
that sort of conservative line
but i think i think as well i think and
i think this isn't the most recent book
and i think that that that focus there
on particularities is drawn out i
haven't read the most recent book i've
just read reviews and whatnot of it i
mean i think it's a turn to
phenomenology isn't it and i say you
know i say that in quotes i think he's
drawing he's gone and
i'm you're not i'm not surprised by that
you know i'm not surprised he's ended up
with phenomenology when he makes this
argument for the particular well i'm
also thinking about paul joseph watson
right back in i think it was 2016 around
the time when the trumpets were really
gaining uh traction he had a shirt made
that said conservatism is the new
counter culture right uh which is
ridiculous and you know i also was
personally offended by the fact that he
would invoke people like kurt cobain by
saying you know there's no great bands
like nirvana anymore and i'm like
[ __ ] gurglebane was the biggest
feminist hugely supportive of lgbtq
rights you name it right i mean he's
[ __ ] rolling around in his grave
right now but you know it did have a
certain kind of traction uh with an
audience right that felt that they were
being marginalized by a pc culture uh
and that to resist it had this kind of
punk quality to it um and i personally
thought this was ridiculous but
well and also isn't it like to fit it
with the comedy theme too i feel like
isn't it the case that also i think
conservatives sometimes will like point
to the comedy case of like pc trying to
like shut down certain kinds is like
look at how uptight they are right like
they don't even want to laugh right and
it's like we're the ones who want to
make space for subversive culture
because we want to allow for these
things it's like the lefties who are
trying to shut all these things down so
that's kind of fits in with this
narrative that conservatives have lately
been trying to develop that let's like
we're the place for the counterculture
we're willing to laugh it's like the
others are all stiff and serious right
yeah no definitely and i think i mean
you know i get you know just to draw
back but the less struggles because i
think you know i
i think i draw particularly here from
the work of sort of todd mcgowan and his
sort of work on universality and petite
and its relation to the particular and
the singular universal and for me i just
the left just struggles if on fighting
that terrain when it becomes about your
you know i can be the subversive one i
mean that was kind of this is what you
get when we have it a lot in the uk i
think it was announced this week on
monday that john cleese will be doing
a documentary on channel 4 a public
service broadcaster in the uk um on
cancel culture and woke culture and i
think he's someone who
you know the craziness of that i mean
this was this was monty python fellow
who was you know their comedy was all
about the formal subversion of figures
of authority um
uh and what you know the catholic church
and everything and now they just sort of
become these angry
old men who are just
well maybe well they're upset aren't
they about being cancelled and they're
not having the right or the freedom to
speak
while hosting your own documentary
and that was the point i tried to make
about constant kissing in the book
constantine kissing in the book is that
um you know this was a man who was
whinging that he couldn't do his set
due to his behavioral agreement but then
managed to get on
all like the morning tv shows and
managed to write in the daily mail you
know
frighteningly the most red newspaper in
the uk you know was able to then use it
as the linchpin for his subsequent tour
um so i think i think there's it sells i
think if you if you go down that line of
yeah
totally i'm curious if and i think kind
of matt earlier was we were talking
about like defining political
correctness and i was curious if you
like how you distinguish it because i
think there's like maybe a common
sensical definition that like you know
non-academics will think about political
correctness
vaguely at least you know i think if you
question them they probably won't be
able to give a coherent because it is
one of those strange categories but then
there's this category wokeness
and it's like you know like i don't know
if you talk about non-academics that's
kind of exclusionary okay i think we
should avoid wary of using that kind of
language
um but i guess i'm curious like how do
you see that like do you do you kind of
have a a distinction or a line or do you
kind of think that there are words for
the same phenomenon i don't know so how
do you think about that yeah it's good i
think i think this is what we're sort of
getting i think this is and it's a
wonderful it's brilliant question to
start with because i talk about the
various definitions of of political
correctness in the book i i didn't want
it to be a book about
essentially just nothing but political
correctness but in the opening chapters
i do look at sort of briefly where the
term came from and how it has this uh
this sort of ideological sort of
pertinence to it where it can be used by
both the left and the right but what i
sort of came to towards the end of the
book was you know perhaps the fact that
it can be used in all these various
different ways and it might not have a
clear definition it's something that can
make it
is something that can make political
correctness comically subversive so is
it a term that in its own ridiculousness
could be pushed and performed in such a
way that it ends up being
ridiculous and daft in in that in that
respect and i think i think that's
something i looked more towards uh the
end of the book this idea that
um
you know
not to be not to be against political
correctness in such a way that our
little correctness is rubbish you know
don't don't follow you know it's it's
matt because then you end up and then
you end up on jordan peterson's side but
in a way where you could perhaps are is
there jokes are there comedy sequences
are there scenes that we could perhaps
use where political correctness gets
played out to the point where its own
inconsistencies are laid there and that
might be something that that is that is
comical it's something that you know
perhaps you know
comedians such as monty python did
particularly well in the past and and in
other forms as well so i think i think
if it's anything you know i talk about
at the end i say you know in theory yes
but in practice no yeah in theory it
works but in practice no let's never
have political correctness because it
yeah let's constantly let it fail in
that regard actually that's a fantastic
segue to one of the big questions that i
had for you which is uh you had a really
great analysis uh of what constitutes
conservative comedy and what constitutes
um i suppose you could call it radical
uh or left comedy and you describe this
uh using kind of a hegelian language
where you say that conservative comedy
always tries to reaffirm the connection
between the universal and the particular
if you think about somebody like the
king right and every now and then it
kind of mocks that or subverts it a
little bit but it's always affirmed at
the end right whereas
radical comedy or left-wing comedy
tries to detach very fundamentally the
universal from the particular right uh
so the kind of joke at the end of
say a kind of diatribe against the king
is that the king still thinks he's a
king
at the end of it right whereas
conservative comedy would say the king
is just a normal man like you but he's
still in charge right so can you talk a
little bit about that and maybe give an
example of somebody who
was a talented left-wing comedian right
somebody who was able to engage in this
probably unconscious like hegelian
project of deconstructing authority and
actually just quickly i'm curious is
that also the where the true comedy
versus false comedy comes in is that the
language yeah yeah so that's so this is
again this is this is uh elenka
chapanjit's um uh definition there of of
of distinguishing between what is true
comedy and and what is false comedy so
the key bit to remember there is is the
sense that in in
false comedy you know she argues and as
i look and as i explore a bit further in
the book is this is conservative comedy
what it does is it keeps the universal
and the particular apart okay so um she
uses the example um of the baron the
toffee knows baron who slips in the
puddle slips on the banana peel uh and
he falls he falls into the puddle of
water and we all laugh at him because
he's a baron but he's just like us he's
human type thing so what it but he still
he gets up and he continues to be the
baron so is that i think that's what you
were getting that um
matthew with regards and i think for me
examples of that i
um
one of the examples i draw upon in the
book is and this was interesting because
again i was drawing i was using upon you
know the same the same writers and the
same comedian was this is that to me
would just underpin uh ricky gervais's
extras where essentially what he was
doing was he was getting notable
celebrities to come onto the show and
perform exaggerated versions of
themselves
but you're meant to sort of you're not
laughing at celebrity or you're not
laughing at someone uh say chris martin
obviously the lead singer coldplay
you're laughing at the performance of
chris martin playing chris chris martin
so you get the separation there between
the two which is which everyone is
patrick stewart i should say yes yes yes
patrick stewart yeah being a good
example there so they just they play
like these sort of crazy versions of
themselves and then they can carry on
it's like you know i say in the book you
know chris martin can leave
can literally leave the studio after
filming his extra scene and carry on
being chris martin but what's particular
i think what's phenomenal was brilliant
in the pancakes i commented she said uh
true comedy is when
the or the way i interpreted it and the
way i read it was true comedy is when
the universe was shown to be
inconsistent through a particular
concrete example
so it's not the
it's not the fact that the baron slips
in the puddle and he's just like every
other human on the planet it's the fact
that he gets up and still believes
himself to be
a baron which is really which is the
comedy so we're laughing at his
presumptuousness
in that regard we're laughing at the
title of baron so there's this sort of
and she uses hegel's concrete universal
just to draw that out and it's something
i do in the book but i think that's
really interesting because to me what
that that started to get me thinking
along the lines of this idea of can
comedy be subversive in what ways can
universals be concretized in such a way
where their own ridiculousness is laid
bare and i suppose i mean there's
there's you know plenty of political
examples we've got boris johnson in the
uk
uh i think you know one of the things
that always got me a little bit about
you know criticisms of donald trump was
that it was always donald trump
besmirching the office you know you know
this man's leader of the free world he's
the president of the united states and i
was like well no does this not show the
ridiculousness of the president of of
the presidency now in contemporary you
know united states the sense that you
know it's the system that gave the ended
up we ended up with him through the
system it might be the system that's
broken if you end up with someone like
donald trump at the end of it so rather
than show so it kept it separate kept
the title president and donald trump
separate rather than show actually what
donald trump did was play out the
the ridiculousness of presidency in its
in its in
its title and i think there's
some good examples i think um
sasha baron cohen i think is quite good
at times playing out
yeah those i think borat borah in
particular i think there's very i think
there's versions of baron cohen i
thought i found i thought his most
recent borat film was was was really
good to be honest with you um in plains
you know you know in performing that
ridiculousness he seems to take things
too
you know to their logical conclusion
where you're left laughing because you
see how ridiculous something is um i
think we have a comedian in the uk
called stuart lee um
who i could have i could have completely
and utterly written the book about
stuart lee in his formal comedy um there
was a phenomenal paper um which i which
i saw in the book which had already
essentially done that so i left it out
but what stuart lee's very good at and
you can see his clips um on youtube and
whatnot is but his comedy is is in
explaining the joke so explaining what
it's weird the joke is itself his
explanation of the joke and why you find
it funny so you end up through this sort
of puzzle where at the end you're
laughing at something for its
ridiculousness so i think he's a great
example of somebody who perhaps performs
this sort of this true comedy this
concrete universal um
yeah i just i draw upon i i provide my
own baron example in the book with a
reference to a famous scene from
you know perhaps the most popular uh
comedy in the uk would be only false and
horses where
um
yes i talk about that in the book a bit
more but yeah i mean a lot of the kind
of points that you make about comedy
reminded me of a comment lecom made
which itself was kind of a joke where he
said uh if a man who thinks he is king
is insane uh then the king who thinks he
is a king is no less so right uh this
kind of idea that fantasies of power
right and needing to recognize the
contingency of all of them but i think
what you said about donald trump is
something that i really agree with right
i remember back i think was in 2018 uh
when he brought mcdonald's into the
white house
and all kinds of so-called radical
liberal commentators were saying things
like this is ridiculous he's undermining
the dignity of the office he's
transforming the presidency into this
kind of clownish enterprise
and what i want to say is like no i mean
in some senses the most radical thing we
want we could do is precisely to say
there is no dignity to this office right
uh he's operating as an imperial hegemon
over the course over the globe uh and
what we want to be doing is consistently
subverting this uh but i don't think
that's what trump was doing by bringing
in things like mcdonald's i think he was
playing out to exactly the kind of
demographic you were talking about by
saying look i'm just like you but i'm
also the president right so now you can
fantasize about what it'd be like to
wield the kind of power and have the
kind of authority i do and project those
kinds of impulses into me
yeah it's it's a it's a thin line i mean
there is literally a picture isn't there
even stood in front of all the
mcdonald's uh big mcdonald's i've ever
seen yeah yeah and you've got that it
reminds me of
the film richie rich because he had a
mcdonald's doesn't he and he's and looks
like you know being yet i think i love
serving mcdonald's but so there is a
comedy to it and i think it's a thin
line because like you said i think that
appeals as that popular appeal that sort
of
look you know hannah the people getting
in mcdonald's you know getting you know
the great american fast food restaurant
uh getting them into save the day type
thing but it's i think the interesting
bit there is is is as i said this thin
line is between finding that funny but
then as you write you know as you said
there or finding the whole
whole performance itself ridiculous to
the point where he's actually playing
out that that ridiculousness um
i think that's something i mean i think
that's essentially i mean it got him
nothing but grief did it but i think
that was kind of you know that was gg's
point isn't it when he when he did that
when he made that comment didn't he
about why he vote for for trump because
i said you know what what does trump do
if not bring to bear the ridiculousness
of
liberal you know he's a product of that
system in that sense yeah this is um
actually this is reminding me and maybe
i'm going to take the opportunity to i
some i've often made this argument a
couple times maybe in the podcast when
we talk about um
um well actually like the monarchy in
canada because we're canadians and like
and like there's a lot of people are
like why do we why why bother with the
monarchy and i sometimes make this kind
of argument that that and what matt was
saying before reminded me um
that i sometimes argue that maybe
there's some kind of like uh helpful
effect that having the monarchy where
it's because somehow i think like having
this symbolic figure and i wonder if
it's similar in the uk
that like kind of takes or like somehow
pulls away like the mystique from the
office of the prime minister because
it's all isolated in this like symbolic
figurehead and it's like i'm glad we
have this the the figurehead who is
supposedly ahead of state doesn't
actually have any power but then like
the person the prime minister is just
like a commoner in the house of commons
and i feel like in the states they're in
this weird dilemma where like because
they don't have a symbolic figurehead
they end up investing the person who
actually has the power with all this
fantasy
that i feel like somehow need not be
there it's like no it would be
ridiculous in canada i'm guessing in the
uk to be like respect the office of the
prime minister it's like who cares it's
like
it's like not really a thing and i think
that that's why i'm sometimes argue with
other canadians it's good to keep the
monarchy it's like it has it's useful
i think i mean that's how i always
interpreted hegel's concept of the
monarch and the fact that it shows yeah
i think it plays out the the paradoxes
of the state it or becomes as you quite
rightly said this symbolic figure
embodies the inconsistency so to speak
it's interesting because i have i i
i'm pr i'm a republican you know i don't
i don't want monarchy or anything but
this is what you're getting at victor
like you end up in this like awkward
situation where actually
i you know i love at the minute harry
and megan mark purely for the fact that
they are just showing up the royal
family and the ridiculousness of that
family and the cruelty of that family
and
all the nonsense you know with prince
andrew and everything going on at the
same time it's almost like
did you ever see the uh get out poster
the meme for that
no no no
you know the the movie with uh the
the peel jordan peels movie get out yeah
get out
so they replaced uh all the characters
in that so it's meghan markle who's the
person who's running away from the
family and this is all
the white royal family like staring at
her honestly you know that's brilliant
right yeah okay yeah i mean it's not
brilliant for poor megan but yeah but
there's that's interesting yeah i mean i
mean that and but that's you end up in
this awful conundrum where i'm a bit
like i'm all i suddenly now become pro
monarchy with megan and harry purely on
the basis that they get to just show up
they're all family it's an odd one it's
not yeah who knows who knows they they
they hold on by their fingernails of all
family purely for the queen i think when
she goes
when she dies i mean one's down isn't
her husband's gone so
yeah i don't know i think when she goes
i think they'll be big big big big
changes probably true it's probably true
but yeah it's just i hate the way like
in america though i just don't like how
there's all this symbolic investment
it's like the person who actually has
the power he has this like almost royal
like the office of the president has
this like royal feature to it that like
is in people's psyche and i feel like
that's actually like maybe bad somehow
to like what yeah i mean it's a
brilliant example because we often like
when people talk about republic if you
if you made the argument for
republicanism in the uk people go what
do you want then a president like the
u.s like as if that's it that's
immediately works and they go and people
go because then we'd end up with tony
blair as president or something or other
or you know what i mean or it'd end up
like i don't know someone some public
figure like stephen fry or something or
other i don't know i don't know they're
not great examples so yours you sort of
end up going now we don't want that type
thing so perhaps
yeah having an old woman
a clownish family at the top who has no
real power just uh let them let them let
them let them absorb the like uh
whatever the i don't exactly know how to
like the term to use but like the kind
of symbolic investment away from the
person who actually has the power yeah
or embody the ridiculousness of having
a nation-state headed by i think and i
think you know perhaps there's a safety
valve there or something or other you
know the you know the silliness yeah and
it's
it's awful because that comes with
obviously all the awfulness of a
monarchy in the history that your body
but
perhaps yeah
no no it's okay um so i wanted to ask
too like uh the sort of critique of
political correctness i mean so i think
at one point in the book it's it's
described as like you know
it's like a safeguarding approach um and
and you say it functions to to undermine
any real capital r
relationship
and um
i wonder if you could talk about
like how that what you mean by capital
are real relationships and sort of like
how you see political correctness um as
interfering with that ability i think it
relates to something you know we were
talking about earlier with like real
comedy um as revealing something and i
guess like somehow maybe it seems like
you're arguing that political
correctness
um prevents that possibility i suppose
or it can it risks preventing that
possibility it's often it's a bit like
you know like you might have pet name
you know the people that you know
the people that know you best or the
closest will have certain pet names for
you that you know if your partner was to
use that's okay and it might refer to i
don't know and particularly idiosyncrasy
about yourself something you might have
done in the past but if for instance a
stranger was to come up to say to it
you'd be a bit like god you know you're
a bit you're getting a bit too close
that sort of thing
so i think what i was getting out there
with this sort of real contact is often
i believe that
it can be through telling a dirty joke
or through comedy that might on the face
of it seem quite um
illicit or or or wrong to even say that
actually you make the truest connection
uh with with individuals and
particularly you know particularly with
you know different you know perhaps
people from different cultural
backgrounds and ethnic backgrounds as
well and i think i think that's what i
was getting at there with that sort of
real
uh that that sort of real contact it's
that idea are you always like that quote
it was um
yeah i think that jijek used about uh
from george orwell he says that you know
if i want to make you know
i can't just i can't just pack pat a
proletarian on the back and say yeah
come on let's have the socialist
revolution i've actually probably got to
engage
in a process and with someone that's
going to take a lot of work if you know
what i mean and i think that's what i
was getting that there with this sort of
real contact it's yeah it's where it's
where does it lie
it's where do those boundaries lie sort
of thing and i think this is really
interesting because you asked me at the
start where did you know where did some
of these ideas come from for the book
and i can only ever come back to one
example um
uh which was with which was with a
colleague i worked so i started when i
started at my institution i mean this
this is in itself an example which i
think brings everything that together
which we've been talking about here but
when i started at my university i had um
into that point in my life as well so
when i started i think it was 24 25
i'd had one black manager and what was
interesting was obviously i'd had this
week of
starting at my institution you're
introduced to numerous managers you
can't remember any of their names by the
end of it and a lot of the managers very
wide middle class would say to me have
you met have you met this particular
manager and i'd be like oh which sorry
which one is that and they'd be black
fella and it always it would always be
whispered they'd touch their face and
it'd be whispered and then i was and
then a couple of months later i was
we gone out for a drink after work and
he was in the pub and i remember
it must have been because i'd had a
drink i don't know but i told him i told
him this joke i said to him i said you
know it was hilarious and because what i
ended up doing was i deliberately
started to say i couldn't remember who
this person was just so i could make a
lot of these people feel uncomfortable
by saying uh he's the black fella so i
told him this joke and he turned round
to me and i was nervous when i said but
he turned around to me and said
what i usually say to that jack is if
you think i'm black wait to see my
[ __ ]
and it was just it was
filth you know we've probably been you
know it can imagine if we'd said that in
a departmental meeting you know that
they'd have been up wrong but
we got on famously after that you know
and there was something about i don't
know
that so
it was trying to articulate that in in
in the book i think which was k and and
again i think gzx paradigm work was the
only thing that allowed me to sort of
explore that i think
it's it's that real contact it's the
dirty jokes you share with with people
yeah where real connection lies and that
that reminds me i think in in your book
too you talk about and this is something
i mean i th all of us actually on the
podcast are fans usually jack and i
think she like share share share this
kind of this kind of view of like um
that he's offering something um
important that no other academics talk
about um but like one of the things i
think
is um this idea that i guess like all
social interaction involves some kind of
risk of putting yourself up out there
and it seems like um you were saying
that political correctness in some ways
is an effort to try to like eliminate
this risk which ends up kind of being
self-defeating and it's like and it's
like i think that maybe the the purpose
or that you're trying to get at is like
we have to realize reckon with that that
there's always going to be some sort of
risk involved in our social interactions
and it's like i guess this kind of
subversive comedy um
can can bring that to the light in in
like a constructive inner subjectively
connective way where we can connect
better with each other and it also
reminds me and i think you bring it up
in the book too like the classic uh
zizek
uh schtick that he has about like
seduction right it's like that that it's
like it's always a trend it always
involves a transgression or the
possibility of trans regression that
then gets retroactively
described as either like a harassment or
successful seduction and
not that you know we want to reduce uh
seduction to being like pure
transgression but there just is there it
just is the fact that there's always a
risk that it's going to be taken up in
this way and i think similarly like your
joke to your colleague could have been
taken up
and you just kind of had to take the
leap and and see what happened
definitely and and i think yeah i mean
it's that idea that you make a pass and
is you're even you're even going to be
seen as a creep for making the pass or
it's going to be reciprocated and
retroactively everything was good and
everything was fine but i totally and i
think there was a formal significance
there in our day-to-day interactions
that sort of and you know moving away
from that sort of risk being regulated
towards telling a joke like you know
what i mean you tell
you know i am denied whether or not i
should use that example there of of of
the colleague at work you know when we
tell a joke and i think it was really
interesting there was um
uh there's a a a book on gg and
performance where the author in there is
a stand-up comedian and he says like you
stand up in front of this room you've
got all the lights on you you often
can't see the crowd so you're talking
into like an abyss and you're taking
this leap of faith when you tell a joke
because that joke might not be funny or
people in the room might not get it um
and i think i think there's a there's a
formal link there
between comedy the actual telling of a
joke uh and the risk involved in taking
a joke something that could be played
with and hopefully made fun of but also
the risk there that's involved in
in every interaction we have um well i
want to actually broaden the discussion
a little bit because this is something
i've always wanted to ask an expert so
conveniently enough here you are uh and
i can ask it so going back to like
elementary school which is how far back
we have to go i remember one of my
english teachers said well the
difference between comedy and tragedy is
that tragedy bad things happen at the
end you know you think of hamlet
everyone's dead comedy it ends up you
know everyone's fine uh that doesn't
really seem like a very satisfying
definition to me though um
and one of the things that occurred to
me is that
tragedy has been very theorized on and
there are a million different
definitions of it you know from well
tragedy reflects on life suffering to
tragedy is about the despair that one
feels about having to be oneself when
one wants to be another person millions
of definitions but it's really hard for
me to think of a good definition of
comedy
in part because it's really hard for me
to even think about what makes something
funny right you just kind of
instinctively know
what's funny and i'm sure there are a
lot of different reasons for that so can
you tell us what is comedy exactly and
why do you think people laugh what do
they find funny or what makes something
funny
yeah that's that's good that's
interesting i think to me it's when
to me i i again and i think this is you
know i'm drawing upon
i think what i'm about to say japan it
sits behind it it's when it's when
something's shown to be inconsistent
it's when it's when you're it's when
something is taken to a a logical
conclusion where you don't s you don't
end up with anything new you don't end
up with anything gained apart from the
fact that what you thought you were
going to see has been reversed or
returned to or you might have just
received the same thing and it's
probably not too clear in the way i'm
necessarily explaining that but i think
it's that it's not necessarily
incongruity i talk about incongruity in
the book i think that's quite a common
uh
particularly in the study of comedy that
the comedy is this incongruity that it's
when something is in is it's like where
something is where it shouldn't be type
thing um
uh todd mcgowan in his book talks about
it being the sort of um the sort of
meeting the dialectical meeting of a
lack with an excess
and he has sort of plenty examples there
so he talks quite brilliantly about uh
hannibal lecter you can actually find
hannibal lecter quite funny because his
jokes are
excessively
based on death so it's the lack you know
and death so it's the meeting of those
two but for me it's when it's when
something that you might take for
commons common sense or taken for
granted is shown to be played out and
being consistent
so comedy's a bit like have you ever
like it's a bit like you know when you
know when you're like you're walking
along a path and like you meet and you
go right and they go right and then you
go left and they go left and you end up
in this weird sort of
tension with some i mean to me that that
would be the naturalness that you get
there the gut because your goal you can
do there is look at the other person and
laugh can't you you know what i mean
because you're stuck in this ridiculous
situation and i think i think it's when
something's made concrete i mean again
that's where i come back to this this
use of hagel's concrete universe was
yeah i think and i think that's what
that's what good comedy does i think
often
well
why do we find different things funny
though this is something that's always
perplexed me so you know back in the day
when i was [ __ ] whatever it was five
years old i watched bugs bunny cartoons
where most of the [ __ ] is about
slapstick and g-jek talks about you know
things like you know the coyote runs out
across a cliff and it really reflects
what you're talking about right there's
this inconsistency because he seems to
be able to transcend gravity until he
realizes what he's doing after which he
falls and that's funny but then you go
on to the other end of the spectrum and
you can think of things like very high
brow comedy right uh think about
something like um
i don't know you know ricky gervais you
know commenting on social political
issues uh or like you said louis c.k
ruminating on existentialism and death
and nihilism in our culture and stuff
very very different kind of end of the
spectrum so why is it that the coyote
falling down the cliff and
breaking his nose or whatever is funny
and these ruminations about death at a
very high level of sophistication are
also amusing what connects these two
things
beyond just the fact that there's an
inconsistency in our expectations and
what occurs that's a wonderful question
that i would have to explore that in
another book because i think that's a
great and yeah to go from the sort of
yeah the very the literal you know the
comic there from the hannah barbara sort
of uh
i'm thinking as well i'm trying to think
there's a connection there because
they're both funny but i think i would
come back to the formal way in which
they're being played out to me i mean
slapstick
i mean slapstick can be funny but i
often wonder if slapstick follows a path
for sort of irony or that sort of
cynical
resignation i don't know if that's if
that's something i would see the two you
know what i mean you can
you can laugh at the coyote because i
don't know it's not you falling if that
makes sense but perhaps the difference
there is sort of uh you know something
that louis ck might have done is you
probably lived it a little bit if you
know what i mean um which is why as a
child you wouldn't find it funny i'm
trying to think of like typical sort of
lewis ck jokes here it's interesting
because you know i i didn't i remember
when i was younger and and ricky gervais
to use it to use him as an example i
didn't find his stand ups that funny but
i think the older i've got i've seen
clips of them and i found them funny and
i remember watching them as when i was
younger and they they weren't funny so i
suppose perhaps there's something there
about experience or at least not that
way in which you might have experienced
that particular
inconsistency or impasse i don't know
it's a wonder that's a phenomenal
question because yeah you said it draws
upon
the george one so much animation i think
is quite good at performing that sort of
perhaps that early i don't know yeah oh
absolutely
the reason i thought the one the first
time this occurred to me was actually
during my undergrad because um
i was reading some socratic dialogue
might have been like the euthyphro or
whatever and you know kind of having a
hoity-toity laugh at how he was just
like owning all these people like
that's kind of clever right uh then i
went out and had a couple beers with
some friends of mine and we ended up
watching i think it was like trailer
park boys and
it was just this long long just like
joke about people getting really [ __ ]
up on dr um like booze and weed and
stuff and i thought it was hilarious and
i kind of was thinking myself like i
don't understand what makes you know
this platonic dialogue funny
and then
seeing mr leahy and the trailer parker
boys get like really [ __ ] up and like
stumble down the stairs is also funny
there's something that connects these
two things but i'm just not sure what it
is so i don't know
yeah
yeah that's yeah sorry it's a big it's a
i mean it's yeah it's it's a complicated
question yeah trailer park boys is
canadian show i'm not sure if you guys
got it in the uk or not but yeah we get
it on netflix and what yeah yeah oh do
you okay yeah i've seen that yeah it's
in the clips of it and whatnot okay
sure yeah i wasn't sure trying to think
of a sort of a uk equivalent but yeah
uh is it mockumentary style if i'm right
yes
yes it is right okay yeah we have
something called this country might be a
bit similar but i question those because
as i said i do wonder if sometimes um
this is something i talk about in the
book between this idea of uh the
distance you know this idea perhaps you
know we are finding those those examples
funny because right cynicism irony
satire are all funny they make you laugh
but i wouldn't call them subversive i
think i think that's why i would
you know perhaps we're coming up with
some sort of typology here where we
would we would you know we would find
something else funnier than you know
than say those examples but i think for
me what they're very good at is they
create that distance between you and
what you're seeing you can laugh at the
silly trailer park
person because they're being deafed and
stupid ha ha ha and i think that's
perhaps interesting that's that's a
dynamic to it that we get this distance
towards it um
we have i think um
uh someone who plays with that quite
nicely is charlie brooker um
yeah
so yeah i'm always curious to know this
like i suppose you know through black
mirror i think it's been quite worldwide
yeah i also lived in uh ireland for a
year and the girl i was dating was
british show we ended up watching a lot
of those ricky gervais shows uh
oh good right yeah so but charlie brooke
i mean trying to book out a career way
before that obviously black mirror i
think he was a guardian uh he was he
reviewed playstation games i think
originally but he had a show called
newswipe and it was essentially where he
just took
he took the mick out of the news but
what he did quite well in that was he
would perform the audience as part of
as part of the show so he would have
these sort of little skits where it
would cut to him
sat on the sofa watching the news and he
would perform he would take it literally
what the news was saying
and i think that was really interesting
because he played there i think with our
own position you know where i'm talking
there about having the distance to the
coyote
you know the coyote on screen falls off
the mountain so to speak and we find
that funny
um he played with that so i think he
performed us as audiences watching
comedy and you know there's clips of it
on youtube no doubt but perhaps there's
something there in it as well i think
yeah so um i've got like a couple more
questions but i think i think matt needs
to go uh
so we'll let him go and then jack if you
don't mind we can just finish up i'll do
a couple more no yeah that's wonderful
thank you for your questions matt that
was um it's just lovely to speak about
stuff so yeah thank you for that and
taking the time
yeah man and best of luck with your next
project okay um and thanks a lot for
coming on no worries
cool all right
all right so um i was wondering about
you say
and i think you know i come from a
political theory perspective uh so did
matt and i think that like when i read
books i'm often as a political theorist
like looking for a kind of like
normative recommendations maybe not
quite the right word but i guess i was
detecting sort of like or at least a bit
of a normative claim about like the
value of comedy or um
might be and and you could correct me if
i'm wrong it's like that maybe it can
help people realize i think i saw the
language of a consciousness of
contingency
um if you recall that and i was
wondering if you could talk about about
what role that plays and and what you
mean by consciousness of contingency or
maybe you might have been quoting
someone at the time yeah but um so i
think so this idea of
i've always read
sort of
you know any and again you know drawing
upon here uh zjx sort of hegelianism
particularly in the relationship between
contingency and necessity but i think
one of the things that what contingency
brings to light is it is it shows that
that that relationship that every
identity has with its non-identity so
its own self in again to come back to
this you know this inconsistency the gap
in being you know uh so to beat the sort
of the dialectical materialism uh that
zj draws upon so for me when i was
talking about contingency is when
something
realizes something about itself that it
hadn't previously seen or hadn't
necessarily been aware of it if that
makes sense so it's
um you know philosophically it's the
idea that the sort of the glass i'm
drinking from is not a mug or a wine
glass and yet those things that it ain't
or those things that it's not con form
part of what it is
type thing so i think that's what i was
getting at there and i think
i just think that's something that
comedy's really good at showing the
ridiculousness not just of our symbolic
you know our symbolic uh you know
mandate the things we use in everyday uh
social interactions not only showing
them to be inconsistent and perhaps a
little ridiculous but also ourselves as
well and i think that's something played
out in the example that i use in the
book as well from the office
is that it you know it's that it's that
realization that perhaps you have been a
bit daft in following
that that logic or in that respect in
that respect so
and i think
that those those have a certain sort of
um
you know those moments perhaps have a
contingency to them i mean i think
that's really interesting isn't it the
idea about
you know one thing i've always found
interested with stand-up comedians is
like they will perform something for 18
months like i suppose the contingency
there comes from the the audiences that
you're
you're doing it for isn't it but like i
suppose sometimes like real comedy so it
happens out the blue all of a sudden
you've realized and i think it's that
that sort of conscious recognition
um yeah
it's really interesting because i you
know i read that along the lines of you
know la khan's traversal of the fantasy
realizing you know that the ego ideal
that you've been subscribed you know
it's a bit daft and a bit nonsense
because you know that and i that's
that's where i suppose that's where i
linked it with the subversive aspect um
in that regard
so it's interesting because i was when i
was reading it i i sort of saw some
parallel maybe between some of the stuff
i've been working on in my dissertation
right now which i'm i'm right now i'm
reading the radical democratic theorists
and i think you cite la clow and moof uh
at one point in the book and
and other people like like roncier and
and butler and and these other people
and i think that one of the things i've
noticed
is that um when they talk about sort of
like agonistic relations with our fellow
citizens they often have it premised on
this idea that um they people need to
have some awareness of like the
contingency of their beliefs
and they can be very like
um
spirited in fighting for their political
perspective in agonistic relations but
they need to understand the contingency
of their own beliefs
um versus the others so that that way
like you know these relations don't
devolve into antagonism so they remain
kind of agonistic or whatever and i sort
of saw a little bit of a parallel where
like at least in so far as it seemed
like what you were saying is that comedy
kind of helps us can help us reveal to
us
the sort of contingency and like the
[ __ ] of like these self-identities
but i guess like the trouble that i have
with the radical democrats and maybe the
trouble that i also have with is like
are regular people and in the case of
radical democracy regular citizens like
are they really understanding that right
like or is it just us theorists who are
kind of like drawing on with our
theoretical apparatus
and that's the trouble i have with the
radical democrats it's like i actually
think that
like having that realization on that
insight is actually quite hard uh it
actually requires education to
understand you know the contingency
discursive contingency and all these
things and it's like and i wonder
whether like
you know comedy they realize something
right because they laugh and i was
thinking earlier based on the
conversation we were having about like
what explains comedy and it's like it
could be that maybe
this background of like
the contingency uh is like actually part
of what makes people laugh but i don't
know but do you think that it's
it's actually like they're actually
realizing that and if they're not i
guess maybe the like more pc person
would return and be like well they might
not they're not even gonna unders it's
not gonna be subversive because they're
not going to understand
these insights so i wonder what you
think about that yeah no it's a
wonderful interpretation it's it's like
you said it i think that's what i would
get you know the thin line here and and
um and if you're gonna if you're gonna
tell a racist joke what happens when
it's just racist or what if when it's
just perceived as racism that's under
which it can be and obviously you know
there are racist jokes obviously
yeah i think that's really interesting i
think it points and you're right to sort
of point there to a more fundamental
issue
in the sense of how do you how do you
how do you put that into some some form
of program or process because it's a bit
like you said you know you mentioned
there rancier and zjx very common you
know will very typically draw upon you
know is the part of no part when he
talks there and it's something you know
todd mcgowan talks about with regards to
the singular universal
but if it's outside like as soon as it
becomes inside you know what i mean or
if it redefines something new when does
it just end up becoming what we had
before type thing and i think
it you know that to me would be a
wonderful explanation of of the sort of
the fundamentalness of the
fundamentality of contradiction and that
perhaps that's why i like the concrete
universal this fact this sense that
perhaps all you can do is at least
make efforts to show the ridiculousness
of something it's a bit it comes out i
think brilliantly through through
something i'm looking at the minute in
relation to nationalism and sport that
actually you know
one thing everybody's very proud of it
you know nationalism is what you know
pride in your country you know feeling
an attachment to this collective but
perhaps the truest form of nationalism
is to actually find your country your
country utterly ridiculous in all in all
senses of the term and that it often it
screws things up it gets things wrong um
it's something you know it's sort of how
i have to approach the english national
football team and that you know yes
we'll get to the final but we're
probably gonna lose that final because
this is england and football
it's the only way i can stomach that but
but again i think like you see i think
that's what you're getting at there is
how you turn that into some form of
political program i mean it's a
political you know it's a politics there
of the negative it's a politics of
uh of of of something that perhaps
yeah perhaps perhaps no redefines the
symbolic order i suppose yeah and i and
and i wonder whether or not it's also
just like the the point about
like that
like maybe comedy is also just useful
for what we were talking about before as
just getting people more comfortable
with the fact that there's always going
to be risk involved in our social
interactions and like that we have to be
willing to take the leap otherwise we're
not going to connect with each other or
something like that like that seems like
the
the part that rather than
consciousness well i mean maybe that is
a form of consciousness of contingency
right because it's like it's like the
risk it's like i don't know maybe that's
wrong but i think no i think i think
you're online it's in some sense and it
it was something i was um thinking about
uh earlier
it's a theme i think you know
particularly on the
in this you know in psychoanalytic you
know philosophical critical theory
interpretations i think this is
something that seems to be at the
forefront of that school of thought the
minute this idea of avowing your
enjoyment in something and then and then
finding limitations to collective forms
of limitation
on that enjoyment i think it's the the
connection that needs to be made
theoretically and practically and
politically
in that sense it was you know it's that
idea i think some sometimes the hardest
thing to do with a racist is to get them
to admit that they enjoy their racism
and
you know and you see that actually in
people that sort of you know always say
i'm not a racist but don't thought you
know i find this or what not and it's i
think if you can avow if you if you
bring to like the enjoyment at play the
undercurrent there of enjoyment that
comes out through comedy perhaps
then you can find
ways around it or collective forms of of
limiting that in some sense um
yeah yeah yeah because like you said are
we just theorizing in the school of
yeah it's always a risk i think when we
get into high theory that uh i think
that's that's so that's something we all
deal with as as theorists
the beauty of the risk though
practically may be that it retroactively
it will never be a risk because it will
redefine
i think that's you know what what badou
gets out with the event i think that's
what gj is getting at there with with
his interpretation the act that a true
act you know it's there what he means in
the past you know i mean when you make
that pass you know when the woman you
know asks the man for his number or vice
versa you know it becomes the start of
the relationship when they're married so
many years later you know what i mean it
was the ultimate that redefined the
logic
if it goes wrong then
one of you for asking me for the number
yeah i suppose that's interesting i mean
that's really interesting if we think of
you know covert i don't know at the
moment you know the complaint of failure
to to politically do something with
covid i think yeah i don't know if that
connection yeah or whatnot
earlier i was cur kind of curious about
and we sort of touched on it a little
bit but but i think it's interesting for
you to take on this topic in a book and
i'm and i think that
we alluded to the sort of the difficulty
and it seems like we're all probably you
know on some version of the left wing
and i think it's like how do you
have you gotten any like
reactions for for like tackling this
topic from people and like how do you
sort of navigate because i think it's
really easy to look like a reactionary
when you're when you're tackling this
and i wonder how have you navigated that
and has it been anything when people see
oh you wrote a book on this and it's
like people maybe make assumptions and
i'm kind of curious about that yeah make
it it's all i i did i did a book launch
for the book my uh uh i had a book
launch and at the start of the book
launch i showed the
the scene the clip from the office where
the black man's [ __ ] joke is told and
the next day you know the person who
shared the book launch came back and
said we've had a complaint somebody's
complained oh god about how that could
have made
someone
is you know a black person feel
uncomfortable and it
and it was kind of like you've really
missed the heart of what you know the
purpose there it you know it was it was
you know it was a it was a clip
obviously
there was an analysis that went with it
it wasn't just that type of thing um and
that's to be honest with you that's the
only it was interesting it came from the
actual book launch i presented um the
the sort of the heart of the book uh on
three other occasions and i'd shown that
scene the scenes as well
and had had and had never necessarily
got a bad response
from it if that makes sense i think it
was this
yeah so it's i suppose that's i suppose
that's the only that's i mean that's the
only openly negative thing i've had it
was something i really you know i i was
very conscious off when writing the book
i just could never i think you know i
think that uh when the episode aired um
which was i i believe 2001 or 2000 so i
just never forgot that joke and
and the way it was played out it was
something i really want to dedicate sort
of a close analysis to because it seemed
you know it got ignored a lot in debates
on on sort of race and political
correctness and the use of comedy and
approaching those i think i didn't want
to lose comedy because i sort of i
wanted to use comedy to subversively
challenge obviously racist beliefs and
assumptions and i think it was um it was
like they want to put in scare quotes or
stand back you know what i mean um or
just yeah it's when it's when things get
told no it's when
that to me is the issue when
we're banning that no that's not
happening and it's like well okay well
then we've lost the debate there i don't
know
it's tough to be in the situation
because i think the temptation to
to absolute eyes is just so it's so
great on both sides that i feel like
people with kind of our uh you know to
include me and matt and you and it's
like uh people who are interested in
well jijac i think is one of the few i
think who's kind of like trying to
occupy this sort of space to like notice
that there's these
dynamics going on that actually like
prevent or or kind of like are
self-defeating that we don't realize in
our political projects and you know
earlier you were talking about enjoyment
and i'm reminded i wonder have you ever
heard of this um
there's this blues musician this black
blues musician who started befriending
kkk members uh
and just because he was so curious about
like why they hated him he's this
american guy and then he started just
talking to them about music and and then
eventually over the years not never
challenging them overtly on their
beliefs but just like talking to them
and then he ended up collecting like
dozens of robes of kkk members who gave
up the clan because of just like
engaging with him
and uh and they made a documentary about
him and there's a striking moment where
he's talking to black lives matter
members and they're all furious with him
right because because he's and i and i
think it kind of makes me think about
how there's in the enjoyment of the
racist but there's also kind of the
enjoyment of the anti-racist right and
it's like and it's like when somebody is
actually i felt like this guy daryl
davis was sort of disrupting that
enjoyment
because he was like you can actually
humanize these people who are racists
and just talk to them and maybe that'll
work um
it's finding that shared absence i think
you know what what what is it that you
both don't have which is why one of you
has turned to racism in the first place
altogether i i think is it you know it's
interesting that
you know the the kkk is a really
interesting example i remember a you
know famous um uh sort of social
psychologist in the uk michael billig
you know he he wrote a lot about uh
comedy and racism and and he he went on
he went on uh
uh sort of kkk uh web kkk websites and
specifically looked at like jokes pages
they have jokes pages on kkk websites
and would analyze the jokes but his
analysis for me always ended up saying
and they're racist well i thought well
of course they're racist you know you've
gone to a racist website to read racist
jokes and the content is racist but you
know there's a formalness to there and i
think it's again something in the book i
really wanted to move away was was
ignore you know get away from the
content the fact that a a black
uh uh blues you know uh singer spoke to
a kkk member and look at the form that
might be taking place the formal logic
of the joke is where you might find
subversion there and it's something that
i tried to explore a bit more um you
know something i tried to look at in the
book is sort of the importance there of
the form and that to me is what made the
ricky gervais
uh scenes i analyzed really interesting
because the form was constantly there
was something that the form was being
played with and used i think in a
particular way and for me the position
of enunciation the person telling the
joke moved in the process of telling the
joke so the content stayed the same the
content was racist the joke's a racist
joke but the way in which the racist
joke
is told
has a formal significance to it which is
i think
which is something i mean that's
essentially what gjp is doing when he
ever he tells his risky jokes isn't it
he's trying to draw attention to the
formal logic at playing the joke he's
telling so get away from the racist
content and look at what it exposes what
assumptions do you bring to to
to the joke before you even heard the
joke
uh maybe one other like curio uh thing
i'm curious about it's just like in
general what led you to an interest in
lacanian psychoanalysis and j'jack like
was that just something you you learned
in undergrad uh like how did that
process uh like lead you because it's
obviously it's a huge influence on
your work so yeah i was
never in my undergrad was i taught zizek
or lacan or psychoanalysis and i think
um
and i think well i'd always say to
anybody and you know perhaps it's the
people we learn on the side so to speak
that actually are the ones that we we
really enjoy listening to um i think for
me it was i remember i remember doing my
phd as well and someone's saying i was i
must have gone on some sort of rant in
the pub probably one night and someone
said to me have you heard of this have
you seen this fella online
and i was like i don't know who and it
was then i remember you know
it was it was slab or gig they were
referring to so i must have i must they
must have seen the connect connection
or some sort there was actually a
colleague who i worked with um at my at
my university
who sort of who who introduced me to to
just work so this would have been um
probably through the back end about 2015
yeah i read the sublime object of
ideology and it was yeah i could my
brain was different after that it was
like sort of i think he gave you he gave
us the language to say what it is i
wanted to say but couldn't articulate in
any user theory before my background was
predominantly sociology as well so i
think that was very sort of you know you
stay away from any sort of psychology or
you know psychologically the two aren't
connected at all but i think
i think you know um
a boredom perhaps was was social theory
predominantly which i think was just
lacking yeah yeah fair enough
uh
do you know the comedian of patrice
o'neill uh he he was american i think he
died like maybe five years ago no no
then no no there's a clip that i always
liked of him where he's i think it was
it's actually thinking about maybe just
like showing you like um the clip i
don't know if you'd be up for that it's
like oh definitely yeah yeah definitely
okay let me see let me see if i can i
mean we may or may not use it in the
final edit but i just thought it would
be it could be interesting okay let me
see if now
is radio cleaning house
after the imus
debacle with me now new city president
now new city for president sonia osario
she took part in a recent protest
calling for radio stations to stop stop
supporting negative language in music
and talk radio and also
our favorite stand-up comic patrice
o'neal thank you sir patrice uh are on a
next i hope not i hope jv i wish jv and
i was gonna lose their job or imus it's
funny this is the thing i i have i don't
know her but i'm assuming that she has
nothing to do with funny so i'ma speak
as the expert on funny funny people
should just be left to try to be funny
what if they're not funny then you made
a mistake but how many listen how many
times has the unfunny how many
unfunny rape jokes lead to rape like i
don't know how many jokes about rape
there are there's a lot but you your
world is not funny your world is
next next on the big story
my world is people trying to be funny
well i mean you think it's okay to try
to make jokes about rape i'm diabetic i
make fun of that i'm a victim i might
lose a toe
but i'm trying to make fun of i'm trying
to make fun of anything i think i can
make fun of sonia
you know
what's happening now is the marketplace
okay
is deciding what's
appropriate or what's not appropriate is
i think the nation is just tired there's
a new mood in the nation what nation the
nation you know what we're tired of
things that are just a nation this paper
in you
i'm not the nation i'm just speaking for
me and funny
you're speaking for the nation or you're
speaking for
yeah you know why because
i remember six years ago
doing uh something against anthony
opening because they were just so
outrageous and their violent images that
they put out to women was just
uncalled for and now now i think you
think they were trying to be funny i
think now people do you think they were
trying to be funny
you know what i don't care if they're
trying to be funny that's what i'm
saying why are you in that business i've
been to your show once and it wasn't
very funny being a woman it was
hilarious when you talked about that's
why she doesn't like me i was in the
paper with her and the joke is hilarious
called the angry pirate and the lady who
wrote it in in her outrage didn't even
know what it meant and anybody who read
it laugh because they know what funny
you're not living in the context of
funny you're living in the context
have every right to be as funny as they
want they can go out and try to be as
funny as they want make as much money
make as much money being as funny as
they want this is what's happening there
is a change in this country people are
realizing they have an opportunity to
speak out
and advertisers are listening
talking you're not talking about you're
not talking to who i talk about you're
not going to get paid as much money
anymore and patrice look at this the
marketplace more cbs radio firings
they've been on they've been on a tear
lately
are they cleaning house or is this the
pc cops running off you know what it is
john
you know what it is while you're reading
that paper it's the pc cops run a mug
you think she's a piece of paper of
course she is she's she has an entire
encyclopedia of of her stance on it but
it's no passion involved it's not a real
this just what she has to say we are
outraged and fired and fired and fight
main calling i'm outraged i am outraged
you should be i am a fool now if i
called you a fool ah
you know what people are feeling a new
sense of entitlement who are these
people
in this country
so here's what here's my question how
can you justify a bad joke a joke that
isn't funny oh wait a minute wait an
attempt that isn't funny doesn't get any
laughs and is about raping a the first
black woman to ever become the secretary
of state in the united states throw that
at me
the attempt is what i'm trying to fight
for the joke may or may funny jokes and
unfunny jokes uh come out of the same
birth that you you don't know if
anything is going to be funny you should
attempt to be able to make anything you
think a joke about rape is doomed to be
not funny it's possible but i've heard
them i've heard you've heard a funny
rape joke
i say a couple watch my hbo special he's
pretty good at it
anyway that's uh
that's a book in itself as well isn't it
my goal yes what an example no i hadn't
come across that example before but that
is interesting there's a book written on
rape jokes i've got it's i was there
because i've always wanted to write a
paper on it but there was a performance
artist a woman who uh who published a
book just of consistently of rape jokes
and uh jesuit writes the like the
preface you know the the introduction
a sort of review of it at the start and
i've always wanted to try and extend
some of the ideas in the book by looking
at this but she's a performance artist
and what she would do
was um the book she would stand on stage
at say i don't know if it was a comedy
festival or she booked out a theater and
she would put the lights all the lights
would be on or the lights would be
shining on the audience and she would
just sit at a stage for like
and read 400 rape jokes
um and it's and it's like
and it's so interesting the stuff that's
been written around it because obviously
like some people laugh at them some
people nervously laugh some people get
up and walk out um i'm gonna have to
find um yeah
that's so interesting and what i also
find interesting about that clip is like
i fee i i thought of the clip when i was
reading your book specifically about
like sort of the the idea of
of like um
that that there's always a risk uh in in
our social interactions that it's like
you have to just take the leap and have
political correct or the way at least it
was defined partially as like you know
trying to try to um eliminate that risk
right and i think that it seems like
what he was trying to argue for there
right is just like you know he's argued
like the attempt that i like when he
says that you know funny and unfunny
jokes come from the same place right
it's like they're both
they're both and it's like you have to
be allowed to try to take that risk take
that chance or something like that
definitely i mean the joke sorry yeah
you're right and i think
it's it's one thing the way i tried to
engage with that in the book was between
was looking and i think it's it's i
think it's
i think uh alenko so panjic
mentions it a couple of times um i'm
trying to think of other books i don't
think todd mcgowan never ever refers to
it but for me what i thought was really
interesting was uh the khan's position
of annunciation and then um sorry the
subject of annunciation and the subject
of enunciated so the enunciated is the
content of what he said and then the
subject of enunciation is the position
from which it's said um
as well i think this is really
interesting because i remember i'd never
seen the example or heard of it but i
think i was what i was listening to um
another podcast by some other people
some other people um and they and um
there was an example there of uh zach
galifianakis who'd gone up to chris rock
and i think and it said and had wanted
to tell
zach galifianakis wanted to tell chris
rock the most racist joke he'd ever
heard
i think to build that sort of weird as
well to build some form of connection
with him but i think what's really
interesting there is that you've
essentially got
a white man telling a very racist joke
to a black man who has no other
what can he do in that instance chris
rock apart from you know offense or find
it funny
slash awkwardly have to find it funny
because what else can he do
in that situation and i think that's
where this
the subject the person from which the
jokes being told is really interesting
because that can move and that and
and what i think that position plays
with is is what we've been thrown so is
the inconsistency the gap in the joke
itself i mean perhaps the issue there
was i didn't
um i didn't obviously see the original
fellas telling the joke but perhaps what
was getting lost there was it was
focusing on the fact that it might have
been i don't know i presume two white
fellas telling a joke about it yeah yeah
two white fellas telling a joke about
raping a black politician
but it's it's
that's focusing on the content and not
the position which i think is
interesting which isn't you know it's
you know the example sorry because that
is a good i want you're gonna have to
i'm gonna have to find that link sorry
and then they got the black comedian
where the position changes so i think
what you're getting out there with the
risk he's trying to expose the
inconsistency of the joke you know what
is this specialization of the first
black politician right first of all it's
not that's that's a shame that's a
that's a that shows that's what i was
trying to get out with the example i
used at the colleague you know the fact
that the fact that um
i'd only had one black manager growing
up in the uk up until that you know is a
problem shows highlights the problem the
fact that people felt uncomfortable
enough to even refer to skin color in
everyday conversation is the problem the
gap that it exposed
so i think um
maybe one last question i'll ask before
i let you go is just
you know
sort of
if a non-academic person were to ask you
so
i saw the title of your book
so like is it okay for me to use racist
jokes like like what like like what
would you say to sort of like because
obviously we've been talk i mean we've
probably answered that question uh
through our discussion but i'm just kind
of i'm interested in how you explain
that
your view based on your research to like
a non-academic uh who just ask you i saw
the title you're you're talking about
this like
should i should i like but should i not
like political should i just say
whatever i want like obviously not but
i'm just curious how do you yeah how do
you yeah so
the book is not a call for more open
racism and the fact that you know i
would reply to that person the fact
you're having to ask the question can i
tell racist jokes therefore
truth to me no you should never tell a
racist you don't even don't even you're
not funny don't even go near it because
you've lost you've lost something there
you perhaps you know what i mean it
takes a certain amount of
you know it's the dexterity that is
there in our social relationships is
that you know what that comedian there
was saying about you know the risk the
sort of the funny and the unfunnier
there
um should you
you know should you tell
i mean
you know i would always say that you
know if that person was asking that type
of question then you know you know how
many black people do you know or how
many you know hispanic people do you
know because clearly you're not
those those jokes would come out to the
point where it wouldn't even feel like
jokes would it perhaps perhaps that's
the point that i'm trying to reach with
the book or or that might be this you
know whatever the ideal that can never
be reached is the point where it would
just be it would just be funny not
opposed to being a racist joke so to
speak which yeah for sure
yeah which is it which is good but you
know as i you know as i say in the book
you know the the joke i analyze is a
racist joke but in what ways is the
telling and the formal logic of that
joke able to elicit something about the
subversiveness of co or the sub of the
way in which comedy can be subversive
and you end up with a different approach
i think to the joke than when you first
hear it through yeah of course it's
played out the jokes played out over
four scenes and i think by the end
you're left
you're left appreciating
the joke
more though than what you would if for
instance you were just to go onto the
street and walk up to somebody
yeah for sure no i mean i think it's
important uh you know and i think uh to
some extent i mean
i feel like that your book is also
it's in drawing attention to like the
subversive potential uh in comedy i
think it's like an important
contribution because uh you know i think
we we've lost
sight of that somewhat on the left
sometimes so i think like being able to
point out like how that can function
um
well that's exactly the left wants its
object the left wants to say this is the
path we take to achieving
the utopia that the of or achieving
equality and i think i don't
that's and that's when he's playing the
rights game and i think actually you
never get you can never get to that
object directly it might take a little
bit of joking and messing about a bit of
a fence along the way um exactly and i
think that that's ultimately maybe
that's sort of how i what i read the
point of the book too it's like there's
not gonna like you there's no you're not
gonna be able to settle things
comfortably like there's just like this
inherent ambiguity that we live in as a
consequence of just like being human
beings with each other and we just have
to like like realize the risks that are
involved in that and like that if we
want to make authentic connections in
authentic solidarity uh it's gonna
involve doing things that some level of
discomfort and to put it simply right
it's like you're not ever gonna be able
to eliminate that discomfort
yeah no definitely yeah yeah that
antagonism i think yeah definitely
exactly well that's good or at least
well yeah that's wonderful thank you for
that
at least i think i might have written it
how i wanted it to be perceived then so
thank goodness good yeah good well jack
thanks so much it's been a pleasure
talking to you and i really appreciate
uh
your time in the book and uh yeah
hopefully uh
we'll uh keep in touch and yeah wish you
all the best no thank you this has been
the best discussion i've had on on the
book so thank you ever so much for
taking the time out to obviously look at
it and read it and speak as well so
thank you awesome yeah no problem how it
was an absolute pleasure
[Music]
you